hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the great work okay so we got in this
room where there's not really anything
that I can do there so I need to quickly
make my way to the other areas of this
underground tunnel system that I have
overlooked I think I went in on just a
rat or a cockroach or is that the way I
came I think that might be the way I
came I'd see the flower bed over there
so if I go down this way I'm certain to
find something that will help me with
his machinery wait a minute
oh yeah no yeah I have I have this
acidic substance here and this looks
like something important do I need to
take this gear with me up but I do need
that hammer
okay so hammer man those cockroaches are
loud for some reason okay I can't carry
that so apparently I'm not supposed to
bring that with me perfectly
understandable hi
your mouth sorry my mouse is messing up
on me I just bought a new Mouse and it's
it's causing me problems it's unreal
you're nice Mouse and I don't know
what's going on where where where where
where where was he
where was he where was he I want to know
okay so that was something all right
then
no big deal okay let me try to loosen
this up with this leer hammer slammer
hammer let's bust it in place I'm gonna
need something that can dissolve rust
but apparently that's not acid my shirts
not acid I am definitely sure it's not
acid let me just double make extra ultra
sure okay it's definitely not well I
mean that's not a from they're
definitely more tunnels that I have not
been down here which is a good thing
because they're all dark and I love the
dark yeah this is where I got startled
by that one monster no big deal okay
what's in here aha what are you what are
you what's in here nothing have I been
in here I don't think so someone the
ceiling there oh it's just messed up
textures okay so nothing back there
oh don't dick with me aha see it didn't
this says petroleum oil so if I hang on
ha ha the valve refuses to move how
about some hefty per story John yeah all
right
wow I'm strong ok the glass jar was
filled with oil ok I've got a glass jar
filled with oil now so I can go back to
the ready room and I can lubricate said
lever and get on my merry way good I
like this can use that on that just like
bled out and needs more force to move
I got your force right here ah yeah
what did that do Raoh I get it it opened
the
hello oh no I'm out of oil ah piss
oh this okay I'm boned alright so you
know we're gonna carry on without any
whale I love that so this will now open
and that was supposedly a monster behind
this I can't see if it opened or not did
it oh god I can't see a thing I heard it
haha okay alright moving on to the cells
by the time Hart live Dury and moraine
met in person their correspondences had
expanded to encompass great minds from
all over Europe and when they sat down
in London to talk for the first time it
marked what many regard to be the true
beginning of the hard lives circle what
is the hard lives circle you asked well
my good boy link my boy dog
holy crap
I mean I really appreciate the good
music I mean sound is everything and if
it's not perfect it is noticeable and I
would love some oil before I go
traversing into the darkness this is the
first time I've ever really been
apprehensive to look around corner to
see an easy at a long time was this a
kid see ok just bars gate okay aha not
gonna get away from me god ah that
finally worked I've had many many a
custom story where that did not work and
is very painful to experience when
you're playing a nice custom story and
all sudden oh you can't progress anymore
wait that was that why can't I touch
that can I pick that up wait a minute
what's going on there something's
interactable maybe I need to find
another to put on there Oh God
oh it's dark is target dark
okay just a bone
I don't wanna let me in let me in let me
in here oh crap oh crap okay ah-ha-ha
there is something in here oh I don't
want to go down there either
I swear guys this is the first time I
mean
this is the first time I really been
really really really really really been
apprehensive about moving forward in a
game
okay okay this is it bad I need to move
the bed and get out of here
no jump-scare no job scared mutant no
jump scared no jump scared okay no way
Amy's know Amy's no whammies I need that
box
give me please thank you thank you
oh stop it with a code noises oh I do
not like okay what was the point of that
why did I need to get through to here
what is over here that is so damn
important oh the candlestick it's dark
now why did it come out which way do I
go oh okay that way hang on there's more
stuff here in there who listen even
looking at me
whew why
oh come on isn't that it isn't that it
isn't that it isn't that it isn't that
it okay alright so mmm
calm down calm down everybody calm down
hey everybody
chill your jets Hey calm your tits Hey
okay everybody just settle down hold
your horses
we got to go back I know you're saying
no Marquess Oh birds don't go back it's
those here okay Nona fessional I go back
or something oh god it was so freaky it
was just standing there
it wasn't looking at me it didn't move
it wasn't menacing in any way it would
just stand in there and it did nothing
I'm like through this darkness I hate
being out of oil is this where it was is
this where I was I think I heard my
throat oh this is where it was I don't
see anything under there
this is a big-ass hallway okay so that's
where I popped out that's where the
candlestick was this is where that
monster was not here anymore
not here anymore okay yeah of course not
why would it be that just be silliness
it probably was never there to begin
with
recall a crazy mark fire no I'm not I'm
not dumb Isaac Clark duh I know okay if
this is judge bass I wouldn't be nearly
the school block from the inside off
balls look the damn dirt look at looking
like a bucket okay all right come on
just a grind
go away please go away go away I don't
wanna play anymore I don't want to play
I don't look play look how I effectively
blocked the whole door with that one
chair that's great
I'm efficient landing I'm gonna go sane
insane no I'm not insane
I'm gonna go sane I'm gonna go to the
same town at least it opened that other
door correct oh man I'm not doing so
well guys oh good yeah I could tell that
things are back to normal because the
safe music started up again
jump-scare rum gums yeah cockroach
obscure plus yard dumpster saltpeter
saltpeter saltpeter yeah used for
gunpowder my research was advancing well
The Shard also allows me to synthesize
with you okay I was enabled to be
before--the though its power is only a
fraction of what hartleb has shown me
before it is proven in suspensive all
needed aqua regia restorer subject body
to physically manageable state was until
the application of the red substance the
stuff from the regular amnesia this does
take place in the actual amnesia world
they've been buried so long in our brick
graveyard that much of their flesh
sloths off their bones even now they are
not truly alive but will be respond to
basic commands I know I can improve on
this given more time but I don't know
how much more power I can drop in the
shard ah
the shard is a shard of an orb smart
okay
sometimes I hear something grumble in
these tunnels I must remember to
strengthen these defences around the
lower sanctum I plan to implement
sensitive mechanisms able to respond to
even the faint heat of a candle heart
Lib would be impressed with my designs
so that's why I thought wait I thought I
lit both cables all their desks that's
another door to the room
you're supposed to be gone ever so
softly don't slam the door
dammit
what is that music I don't I remember
that music oh god the freaking goats I I
love and hate this music at the same
time and I have no idea where I'm going
where am I going
is this where I found that's where I
found the candle how the bloop and
blooper do I get to where I need to be
that's where I went in this is where the
first one in okay so I'm like
everything's dark and I can't see
anything I'm sorry that you guys
probably can't see anything this whole
episode I'll try to raise the brightness
a bit and postive it's too dark but I
mean there's only so much I can do
without distorting the image alright
this is not the place where I got the
candle this is the place where I find
that I will die hey where was that
monster where was that ma that's die
this is the candle room no where is this
I don't know I don't know where half of
these things lead iced room where the
monster was this is looping back you
guys can't see a thing I can't see a
thing we all can't see anything that's
locked from the other side we need to
find a way around do I have a key ah
maybe this da balls I thought that was
totes mix croats gonna be the answer all
right
whoo I would love to shake the hand of
the guy who did the music in this one if
it's the same guy who did the whole game
by himself that's even more impressive
okay so there was nothing in this room
that I was cowering in correct I do not
believe so there wasn't any other
tunnel-like to Goa nomina I need to
stand in the light and think for a few
seconds before I yell my my head goes to
pot okay so here is door here it's
another entrance into that room I need
to find it key to get to that door how
do I find a key in the darkness I can
barely see with my eyeballs
for another come on there's got to be
more light sources I don't even see
torches on the wall I do not this is
awful
oh and there's another one okay I guess
that's a little bit okay wait no this
isn't the room that I got the torch
candle from what is the room that I got
the candle from good boy I'm gonna be
wandering around these places for a
while now is this the room I got to get
oh yes this is the room I got the candle
from I hang on let me go back out
actually I'm I'm running out of time
here
dammit I was hoping that I was gonna be
able to make a little more progress in
this one I made quite a bit but just a
little more so if you guys want to throw
me a hint down in the description you
know how it used to go when I did these
long and these because some stories you
know how I used to go so if you guys
want to toss me a little hint
is do I blow it up blow up maybe I blow
it up okay so I've got to find a way to
blow it up and toss me a head down
description so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]